[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue d'un point de
vue c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver
avec que nos deux invités du jour bon
soit gabriel cluzel vous êtes
journaliste rédactrice en chef du site
boulevard voltaire vous également
essayiste et votre dernier livre
enraciné nous sommes tous d héritier a
été publiée aux éditions arte bonsoir
chloé morin vous êtes politologue
associé à la fondation jean jaurès c'est
votre spécialité c'est l'analyse
d'opinion et la communication politique
et vous avez publié c'est votre dernier
livre le populisme au secours de la
démocratie pour l'interrogation c'est
publié chez gallimard dans la collection
le débat je vous propose de commencer
par la communication gouvernementale
autour de ce qu'il est convenu d'appeler
1re confinement même si le terme n'est
pas assumée vous avez peut-être pris
connaissance de ce document qui
synthétise la communication des pouvoirs
publics et ça s'appelle de temps avec
les miens dehors en citoyens et il ya
une façon de nous parler qui est assez
particulière peut-être que c'est
intelligent où on va en débattre
mais par exemple on nous dit je ne me
rends pas chez les autres jaer
régulièrement mon logement dehors
j'évite de manger ou de boire si je ne
suis pas seul le mort à vous avez été
conseiller en charge de l'opinion
publique de deux premiers ministres jean
marc ayrault puis manuel valls
quel jugement portez-vous sur cette
communication dont beaucoup disent
qu'elles infantilise les français la
communication ça a forcément ça a pour
but de faire passer un message simple on
de simplifier les choses
donc il ya toujours un côté un petit peu
caricatural là la difficulté en fait le
problème auquel le gouvernement est
confronté c'est un problème de nature
politique c'est-à-dire confiné c'est
simple à comprendre des confiner ces
cinq un peuple à comprendre mais ils
nous ont inventé une formule entre les
deux où on est confiné dehors ou des
confits nez dedans et donc ils ont la
difficulté de faire comprendre aux gens
des règles dieu qui sont absolument pas
simple 12 22
d'essayer d'inventer des trucs hyper
simple et des slogans un peu quand l'air
un peu débile pour essayer de ne
serait-ce que un slogan à la limite si
on ne trouve stupide c'est pas grave
le tout c'est qu'on le comprenne et
qu'on leur tienne là l'occurrence c'est
quelque part réussi puisqu'on en parle
la preuve alors le président szysz
trinquant qu'on interrogeait il ya deux
semaines même pas dix jours sur bfmtv
expliquer que non non il ne voulait
vraiment pas infantiliser les français
je fais depuis le début de la gestion de
cette crise vous me l'avez souvent
entendu dire le pari de la
responsabilité je ne suis pas favorable
à l'infantilisation de mes concitoyens
vous le croyez gabriel accuse l ou es ce
que vous avez l'impression qu'on
s'adresse à nous comme si on était des
enfants d'école primaire
oui on a malgré tout que ses aisselles
l'impression que c'est la c7 raid rue
rhétorique là qui a été adopté c'est un
peu celle du lapin dans le métro fait
attention ne mets pas tes doigts dans la
partie va te faire français et en plus
il parle pas c'est bon on le dit
l'internaute qui n'habite pas paris
c'est pour le métro pie ix métro
parisien il est devenu célèbre il est
il est devenu très célèbre ce lapin pour
tous ceux qui ont fait un séjour dans le
métro il est très vite comment ils en
souffrent oui oui sauf que en
l'occurrence les français ne sont pas
des enfants si on joint à l'orias la
formule mais il ya aussi l'immixion file
dans la vie privée dans l'intimité des
français qui est moi je crois que jamais
aucun gouvernant de céder été introduite
dans les foyers avec un tel luxe de
détails jean castex
il nous a dit je serais heureux de
pouvoir annoncer aux français qu'ils
peuvent serez en place et donc on a
compris en creux qu'il s'était lui qui
décide et quand on avait le droit de
s'embrasser c'est pas rien moi j'ose
dire que je n'embrasse mes enfants je
suis une affreuse dissidente et et il
dit également ben non pas de barbecue
entre amis
là il a dit récemment pas de chasse aux
oeufs pas de chasse aux oeufs après a
cru que ces voiliers cc c'est pâques des
déjeuners familiaux donc c'est allé très
très loin comme finalement des parents
envers des enfants aller très loin dans
l'intimité des gens donc ça a quelque
chose d'un peu d'un peu agaçant déjà
parce qu'il ya cette phrase célèbre
bibliques ou en tout cas d'une épître je
crois par en exaspérer pas vos enfants
et en plus ils ne sont pas il se trouve
qu'ils ne sont pas les parents en fait
ils ont ils ont une mission qui leur a
été confié par les français et ils n'ont
pas à se poser ainsi en commandes hier
en censeur et cela passe d'autant moins
que évidemment on peut pas dire qu'ils
soient irréprochables dans dans tous les
domaines et c'est un euphémisme
donc je crois que la posture de angela
merkel je sais pas si vous avez suivi un
peu mais cet après midi elle est revenu
sur sur une décision qu'elle avait prise
est là elle a laissé un journaliste de
france télévisions qui avait twitté un
peu vite hier angela merkel a annulé pas
qui c'était extrêmement fort que sans ce
même annuler la fête de pâques
donc en réalité elle avait interdit
enfin il avait dit que les célébrations
ne serait pas autorisée elle avait
confiné tout le kent et là elle est
revenue là dessus sans doute devant la
bronca et elle a dit écoutez j'ai fait
une erreur d'ailleurs c'est vraiment ma
propre responsabilité et j'en demande
pardon aux allemands faisait jouer comme
ça
regardons et c'est ma responsabilité
c'est moi et je crois que c'est une
forme d'humilité qui serait bienvenu et
on sait qu emmanuel macron aime beaucoup
s'inspirer d'angela merkel
on a envie de lui dire là c'est le
moment c'est mieux que de dire les
français sont pas assez subtil pour
comprendre et ses deux petites gaffes
par le passé qu'ils sont pas le fait des
manuels macro mais de la majorité je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez pisode
voilà là dessus et l'humidité c'est
clairement ce qui manque
enfin disons que l'arrogance c'est une
des critiques qui revient le plus dans
l'opinion vis-à-vis de d'emmanuel mâcon
spécifiquement et puis la majorité en
général et que a contrario l'humanité
s'était par exemple ce qui a réussi à
edouard philippe
quand pendant le premier confinement
quand il essayait d'être plus pédagogue
sur les mesures qui étaient prises c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on retourne à
quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
autoritaire affirmatif
la difficulté qui est celle de
l'exécutif je pense moi je partage ces
critiques là mais je pense qu'ils sont
aussi qu'il faut voir le fait que
lorsqu'ils ne font rien lorsqu'ils
prennent pas de mesures contraignantes
ou qui ne donne pas de recommandations
il ya aussi un procès qui l'aurait
entente et de ne rien faire
or entre deux procès celui de ne rien
faire et celui de trop frère à une
époque on a tendance à judiciariser un
peu tout les choses et quand la vie en
plus est en jeu je comprends pas ce que
c'est aussi la culture de la haute
administration et c'est la culture d'une
partie des responsables politiques
je comprends qu'ils pensent tous vers le
ceinture et bretelles en fait alors dans
la série regardez comme on nous parle
je ne résiste pas envie de vous faire
réentendre ce moment d'anthologie
il est signé rémy salomon alors remise à
l'espace jérôme salle au moins c'est pas
le patron de la la haute autorité de
santé qui nous annonce les mauvaises
nouvelles le jeudi soir c'est le
président de la commission médicale
de l'assistance publique-hôpitaux de
paris c'est un éminent professeur et
voilà les instructions qu'il donnait
pour les personnes âgées juste avant
noël
donc on peut aller chez papi mamie
annuel on ne mange pas avec eux on coupe
la bûche de noël en deux papys et mamies
mange dans la cuisine et nous sommes en
jeu dans le dans la salle à manger
c'est des choses aussi ça non mais c'est
parfait voir l on va même manuel même à
noël parce que même si on a pris les
précautions avant on peut quand même
avoir un des fois c'est plus que c'est
ce que sept jours le la période
d'incubation
si si je transmet le virus a passé lire
in blue c'est pire que tout comme enjeu
comment je vais vivre ça après parce que
papy mamie ils ont un risque sérieux de
d'être en réanimation et deux mâles et
éventuellement d'en mourir
alors soyons honnêtes rémy salomon après
a dit qu'il regrettait de s'être exprimé
de la sorte en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que je vous donne mon avis
mon nom bonne vue personnel moi je me
suis fait un devoir de d'avoir ma mère à
ma table pour noël comprenant toutes les
précautions d'usagé en disant bah non je
refuse qu'on me parle comme ça le danger
c'est que ce soit contre productif ce
type de communication peut-être qu est
mort annoncé que les gens ça les énerve
et du coup il faut au contraire
alors il ya une partie des gens que ça
peut énerver je pense que c'est une
minorité enfin d'aller jusqu'à faire le
contraire je pense que c'est plutôt une
minorité
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut voir c'est
que sur ce type de choses il y à une
partie de la population qui est
surinformés qui est nourri des infos en
continu etc etc et donc qui sait tout ça
mais la polémique autour de ça a au
moins une vertu c'est le fait que
beaucoup plus de gens en entendre parler
et même s'il trouve ça bête ils vont
quand même se dire bon je fais attention
et globalement c'est une manière
indirecte d'atteindre le but même si
c'est vraiment pas comment dire c'était
vraiment pas intentionnel et la pole en
fin les propos en eux mêmes sont bêtes
mais je pense que l'effet collatéral
c'est plutôt celui là c'est le fait de
beaucoup de gens qui en fait n'en ont
rien à faire de la politique ne regarde
pas les débats en ont entendu parler et
du coup ce sont peut-être dit bon bah
dans quelles conditions j'ai organisé et
noël est ce que c'est bien safe on avait
consacré une couverture du figaro
magazine à ce sujet c est en janvier
dernier on avait titré sahara était
d'infantiliser les français reprenaient
les extraits deux derniers essais de
mathieu laine qui est un auteur libéral
et
qui disait la crise sanitaire n'est pas
gérée avec les français mais malgré eux
le pouvoir au sens large politique et
administratif agit comme si nous étions
incapables de nous prendre en charge et
s'adresse à nous comme si nous étions
des enfants
finalement c'est ça la question des
abris cluzel est ce que le gouvernement
utilise ce type de communication pour
être le plus efficace possible
ou bien parce que il considère que nous
ne sommes pas des êtres responsables à
votre avis c'est quoi la sans doute un
peu les deuils et volonté de bien faire
au départ mais il est un fait qu'il ya
là la tentation de se dire que eux sont
les sachants avec nous nous sommes les
irresponsables donc c'est très gênant
delà du fait que c'est agaçant parce que
c'est culpabilisant ça pas besoin de
l'être moi contrairement à vous je pense
qu'il ya peu de monde qui est pas
informée sur ces questions là compte
tenu du matraquage urbi et orbi la 10e
sur l'autoroute il a encore marqué sur
les périphériques ne avec le coville
gardez vos distances oui j'allais pas
sauter sur une voiture sur la voiture
devant donc il ya des risques pas d'y
échapper
mais surtout on se renseigne que ça peut
être un c'est plus le changement des
règles sans arrêt oui oui bien sûr il
faut les faire donner un an
j'entends bien mais je crois que
globalement les français n'ont pas envie
de tuer leurs grands parents leurs
parents ils sont très attentifs à tout
cela donc en rajouter en les prenant
pour des enfants c'est un peu ridicule
et puis c'est une façon de les tenir au
creux de la main parce que d'aider des
enfants irresponsables on les met sous
tutelle et la tentation est forte de
finalement de toucher aux libertés
fondamentales moi c'est peut-être ce qui
me ce qui me frappe le plus dans cette
crise on a quand même notre devise est
liberté égalité fraternité moi je me
sens quand j'étais à l'école on faisait
copier des lignes de paul eluard
lesquels public sur liberté j'écris ton
nom et je trouve que là finalement on
s'assoit assez vite sur les libertés
sans qu'il y ait alors on l'a on l'a
beaucoup dit mais c'est un fait sans
qu'il y ait beaucoup de contrôle ni du
côté du législatif ni des français
eux-mêmes sous prétexte qu'il faut faire
vite il faut prendre des décisions et
qu' il ne faut pas tergiverser donc au
delà du côté peut être amusant ou
agaçant ce qui est le plus inquiétant
c'est cette atteinte aux libertés parce
que jusqu'à quand ça va ça va s'arrêter
moi j'ai entendu
riel est elle qui dit non la règle des
six est terminée il faut pas invité fo
invité personne chez soi voilà alors il
ya un journaliste qui lui a dit oui mais
néanmoins en personne ne peut vérifier
et il a concédé que personne ne peut
vérifier qu'on nous restons maîtres chez
nous en principe donc mais c'est vrai
que c'est c'est comment dire une
dialectique qui fait un peu peur parce
qu'on se dit à quel moment considérera
déjà qu'on est débarrassé du virus et
qu'on est con recouvre toutes nos
libertés et et les libertés cc
individuel c'est important alors ce que
je remarque quand même c'est que dès que
ça gronde
le gouvernement fait un peu ma carrière
on l'a vu avec les commerces
ll est comment dire les corps de métier
qui avait montré les crocs lors du
précédent confinement on les a laissés
ou avec l'attestation de sortie et on la
vit à qualité à s'en sortir dans la vie
avec la messe
autant en allemagne on a commencé à
parler de supprimer de suspendre les
célébrations en france on a souvenir de
des manifestations des recours en
conseil d'état donc on n'y a plus
retouché et les attestations évidemment
ça là aussi ça c'est ça a déclenché une
forme d'hilarité mais qui d'une part
décrédibilise le gouvernement et puis
qui montre que cette crise a agi comme
un catalyseur sur no comment dire ceux
sur nos lacunes c'est à dire sur nos
défauts c'est à dire que nous sommes
dans un une sur administration un peu
courtelinesque et bien là on l'a vue
extrêmement déployée elle aussi ses
infantilisant puisque l'école moi je ne
sais pas si vous avez des enfants en âge
scolaire
moi je passe ma vie à signer des papiers
pour un oui ou pour un non pourrait
autoriser à faire si à faire ça voilà
alors on est revenu sur les attestations
mais quand même pour vous amuser un peu
parce que j'ai creusé le sujet il reste
dans les attestations le motif a causé
promet de son animal de compagnie après
19h alors un journaliste de france info
assez intelligent a dit à l'ats comment
dire le porte parole du ministère de
l'intérieur
oui enfin quand on a un chien en laisse
il ya peut-être présomption n'est
peut-être pas besoin d'engager cette
passion à elle a dit oui mais n'ont pas
forcément etc le voilà donc voyez où il
reste encore quelques quelques petites
perles danser dans ces attestations est
assez critique sur twitter on vous a
posé la question trouvez vous que les
français sont infantilisés par le
gouvernent
et vous répondez oui à 75% et
n'est ce pas au fond un reflet de notre
société française nous dit je peux t'y
74 sur lefigaro.fr
les français sont déjà ultra assisté est
le même nous dit après 60 millions de
procureur ça c'était une expression qui
avait été employé par emmanuel macron
maintenant nous sommes 60 millions
d'enfants philippe nous rappelle sur
youtube le coût de la bûche de noël avec
papiers mamie bah oui cher philippe en
pensant à vous on vous la rediffuser
nicole 06 considère que ces slogans sont
à fond utilisant au possible
en revanche sébastien sur lefigaro.fr
nous dit infantilisation peut-être mais
que penser des trop nombreux
comportements de notre de nos sites
concitoyens irresponsable quand même
marrant vous qui connaissez bien le
l'administration de ce pays est ce que
vous pensez qu'il y a chez les
technocrates on va dire une sorte de
complexe de supériorité par rapport au
français moyen entre guillemets oui à la
très profondément la halle à l'idée
qu'ils savent mieux avec eux et que vos
fonds il ya un attachement et je suis
assez d'accord avec avec ce qui vient
d'être dit on a un problème de culture
démocratique au fond c'est à dire que
d'un côté dans la population
on a quand même un consentement résigné
à une forme de gouvernement qui
dialoguent que peu qu'ils délèguent
peu qu'ils partagent pas le pouvoir et
qui centralise quand même le pouvoir
notamment entre les mains de du
président et ça quelque part on peut on
peut dire oui que les libertés avaient
été restreintes et que personne n'est
dans la rue enfin très peu de monde et
dans la rue pour protester
donc là dessus il ya un problème
vraiment de culture en attendant ce
effectivement a considéré que le
dialogue c'est du temps perdu que quand
on vote une loi vaut mieux la beauté en
une heure que en une semaine parce que
parce que parce que le temps passé à
discuter n'enrichit pas la loi mais
forcément et du temps perdu
on a tout un tas de choses qui
profondément à mon avis on sont dans les
représentations très ancrée et son
problématique au regard du
fonctionnement d'une démocratie normale
et après j'ai oublié votre question du
mcdo c'est est ce que les hauts
fonctionnaires il est donc cette culture
là on la retrouve chez les hauts
fonctionnaires ou c'était pour dire que
c'est pas que les hauts fonctionnaires
et on a un problème mais je suis
vraiment plus large mais chez les hauts
fonctionnaires on a en plus l'idée qu'
on a les meilleurs diplômes on a les
meilleures connaissances techniques etc
et donc notre devoir c'est faire le
bonheur des gens y compris malgré le oui
ça c'est pour le coup est donc la
meilleure loi c'est celle qui sort de
l'administration et pas celles qui
sortent du parlement et qui a été
discutée rediscuter
c est pour ce que ce sujet de la
fracture entre la haute fonction
publique et le pays intéresse je renvoie
votre votre avant dernier livre les
inamovibles de la république c'est d'un
autre livre dont je vous propose de
parler maintenant il est écrit par une
de nos consoeurs du figaro eugénie
bastié ça s'appelle la guerre des idées
ça a été publié chez robert laffont
c'est une enquête au coeur de
l'intelligentsia française est l'un des
thèmes qui est discutée dans ce livre
c'est de savoir si les intellectuels de
droite ont entre guillemets gagner la
guerre des idées alors gabriel cluzel
vous êtes la rédactrice en chef d'un
site boulevard voltaire qui est
fièrement ancré à droite
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
d'avoir gagné non je crois qu'on peut
dire simplement que peut-être là la
droite relève la tête mondial et que le
magistère de gauche qui étaient quand
même dominant majoritaire et est bien de
temps en temps rencontre un petit peu
d'opposition pas beaucoup en réalité
mais néanmoins il se sent peut-être
menacé alors il ya plusieurs raisons je
pense il faut s'entendre pour une sur
les mots gauche et droite passe quand on
a longtemps
considérer que la droite s'était
finalement le libéralisme face à la
gauche c'est à tiko et on voit bien que
la ligne de fracture aujourd'hui est
différente disons qu'aujourd'hui je
pense qu'elle se situe entre eux pour
faire vite des conservateurs enraciné
soucieux de transmettre et fier de ce
qui est grosso modo de ce qu'ils ont à
transmettre et puis des progressistes
plus mondialistes peu enraciné
précisément et qui sont plus dans une
optique de de déconstruction même si
évidemment d'entre dans ces deux camps
il y à toutes sortes toutes sortes de
nuances alors pourquoi aujourd'hui la
gauche et le magistère de la gauche
s'est remis en cause le premier si je
puis dire c'est que c'est dangereux en
fait d'avoir un magistère jeu
précisément d'être d'avoir l'impression
que ce qu'on dit est un dogme ou deux
fois parce qu'on devient
intellectuellement par et cela je pense
que l'intelligence à elle n'est
justement enfin le la réflexion menée du
frottement des intelligences donc ça
fait longtemps qu'il n'ya plus de vrais
débats sur les chaînes télé ça
recommence mais sur les l'échelle sur
les on a eu pendant longtemps même dans
les universités on découvre un ya une
espèce de là aussi de deux dents les
sciences sociales notamment un certain
nombre de théories qui sont développés
sans rencontrer d'opposition avec des
étudiants je dois dire ce que j'en ai je
les ai rencontrés quand je n'en ai pas
fait partie c'est à dire en montant
c'est-à-dire des étudiants qui viennent
un petit peu schizophrène c'est à dire
qu'ils sont pas d'accord force
nécessairement ils sont leurs
enseignants leurs enseignes
mais ils ont appris dans une espèce de
forme de dhimmitude intellectuelle à à
régurgiter ce qu'on leur ce qu'on leur
enseigne parce qu'ils savent que c'est
le moyen pour avoir des leurs examens
comme aujourd'hui on peut le dire pour
un manifestant a été relevé donc c'est
ce même si c'est pas que cela mais par
comme une étudiante qui par exemple
répondre et on a cru t1 écriture
inclusive même si elle a pas envie
d'écrire en écriture est visible parce
que sa prof les écrire l'écriture
inclusive donc elle elle juge nécessaire
de le faire pour comment dire ne pas
mettre en cause la suite le bon
déroulement de son enseignement est là
donc c'est ce qui explique aujourd'hui
donc la gauche est parti dans une espèce
de comment dire de course folle avec des
dès qu'ils deviennent spéciale
particulièrement hors sol parce que je
pense que la gauche à deux tropisme
malgré tout c'est le comment dire
l'idéologie et peut-être l'utopie alors
elle s'est décrochée du réel et
aujourd'hui on a le sentiment que le bon
sens s'est réfugié à droite vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes qualifiés de
droite si vous consommez de la viande
vous dit joyeux noël vous parlez de
france et et vous dites que
l'immigration cc c'est un problème en
france c'est vous êtes vraiment limite
fascisante
or c'est le réel parce que le tropisme
de la droite avec tous ses défauts
elle en a c'est d'être attaché au réel
et à l'empirique donc elle ne s'est pas
décrocher je pense de la réalité des
français comme a pu le faire
la gauche tuez moi si on retient cette
définition de la droite proposées par
cap l'accusé est ce qu'on peut dire que
ces idées là elles sont de plus en plus
ancré dans la population et que donc la
droite aurait gagné entre guillemets la
guerre des idées dans le pays mais qu'en
revanche les élites on peut penser au
système universitaire ou culturelles ou
même assez largement médiatique je pense
en particulier aux services publics dans
lequel il ya clairement des idées qui
sont favorisés par rapport à d'autres là
la gauche règne encore est ce que ça
vous va cette dichotomie ou ça vous
paraît abusif
je crois que dans le livre de génie
bastide faut citer l explique quelque
chose qui me semble très juste c'est que
personne ne pense avoir gagné c'est à
dire que la droite explique qu'elle est
en minorité mais la gauche explique
qu'elle est en minorité aussi et qu'elle
est maltraité et puis toutes les
familles politiques quelle qu elle
décrit se vivent plutôt en minorité
et pas en dynamique et ça je trouve ça
très intéressant
je ne suis pas sûr que lle que la
frontière entre droite et gauche elle
soit de l'ordre du pragmatisme versus
idéologie je pense que des deux côtés il
ya de l'idéologie sa porte juste pas sur
les mêmes choses et que des deux côtés
il ya une forme d'attachement au réel
mais juste pas sur les mêmes thématiques
par exemple on peut très bien dire que
la gauche est pragmatique sur la
question de la pauvreté parce qu'elle
regarde comment elle se forme etc
et voilà c'est pas c'est pas
spécialement
comment dire déconnecté et
l'affrontement idéologique et enfin
c'est pas l'idéologie qui est malsaine
c'est le fait de ne pas se confronter en
fait est de ne pas vouloir se confronter
et c'est de ça dont on a manqué dans les
médias peut-être mais en tout cas en
politique
certainement c'est à dire que moi c'est
ce que j'explique un peu dans mon livre
fut convaincu que dans les dernières
années une part du vote populiste et de
l'abstention vient du fait que les
offres politiques avaient l'air d'être
des nuances de gris la droite c'était un
truc un peu et d'une fin c'était c'était
une gauche un peu plus dure et la gauche
c'était une droite un peu plus sympa
faim mc relèvement ben oui c'est à dire
que du coup on offrait pas aux gens des
vrais opposition entre des choix de
société et donc à ce moment là on va
chercher la différence on va chercher à
changer la vie entre guillemets en
votant radicalement différente donc
populiste quand je dis populis et donc
les extrêmes de l'échiquier politique
pour aller vite la droite at-elle gagné
la bataille des idées
c'est l'autre question que nous vous
posons sur twitter à vous qui a nous
fait l'amitié de nous suivre en direct
et la réponse est non à 64%
léon sur twitter nous dînons donc il est
d'accord avec la droite n'a pas gagné
mais elle se bat mieux trois petits
points et y arrivera point d'exclamation
c'est un signal d'encouragement pour
gabriel cluzel michael sur youtube
la bataille des idées se joue à
l'université dans l'école républicaine
et on a bien vu qui y régnait momo
premier sur lefigaro.fr la gauche est
devenu un parti islamiste par
clientélisme confère la mairie de
strasbourg en l'occurrence vous faites
allusion à cette subvention que la
nouvelle maire de strasbourg europe
ecologie les verts souhaitent donner à
une mosquée en construction
et puis à cette réflexion 2e 2 sur
youtube c'est intéressant car blake usa
je vais vous faire réagir là-dessus je
crains que l'échec de fillon et le
désengagement de la droite sur les
sujets sociétaux seul domaine où elle se
différencie de macron les rendus
invisibles
là aussi il revient sur cette définition
je réponds sur la question de la provôté
moi je crois que c'est le contraire
c'est la droite qui est pragmatique en
matière de pauvreté parce que notamment
sur les questions d'immigration elle se
rend bien compte comme une bonne mère de
famille mon père de famille qu'elle doit
s'occuper préférentiellement de ses
enfants et qu'elle ne peut pas
accueillir le monde entier sinon c'est
tout le monde entier qui qui sera qui
sera qui sera malheureux ou en tout cas
elle doit s'en occuper
en deuxième lieu après s'être occupée de
ses propres enfants oui et donc je crois
qu'au contraire la gauche est
actuellement est en train de perdre
aussi sur ce terrain là parce qu'il ya
tout un tas de français atteints de
pauvreté qui ont eu le sentiment d'être
abandonnés par la gauche mais sur la
question de la visibilité non je crois
qu'une recomposition
c'est vrai que la droite au moment de la
faire françois fillon a eu l'impression
d'avoir été spoliés de icc senti
menacé même au moment des européennes
quand bellamy a malgré tout il suit un
semi échec sur des programmes que l'on
savait sociétal compte tenu de la
personnalité de français xavier bel ami
mais je ne crois pas que ce soit le cas
précisément on est en train de sortir de
cette ambiguïté de la définition de la
droite qui que l'on a confondu avec
l'ultralibéralisme pendant longtemps
vous l'avez dit finalement les régimes
de droite de gauche sont fallait les
gouvernements se sont succédé sans qu'on
voit très bien la différence est ce que
c est finalement la cuvée de cette
fusion vous l'avez dit aussi guillaume
c'est emmanuel macro ces fameux ruban de
möbius dont parle michel c'est à dire
qu'en fait le ruban de moebius vous
connaissez en fait sur un ruban passé
les deux faces d'un même ruban par
exemple l'ultra libéralisme économique
et l'autre phase de l'ultralibéralisme
sociétale et finalement ils sont avec
les mêmes ressorts le/la libéraliser les
marchés pour plus de consommation c'est
comme ça c'est joue c'est finalement le
même jeu si je compare avec la
libération sexuelle que libéralisé
l'acte sexuel pour plus de conseils
soyez il ya des ya des formes de de
recoupements et je pense que donc le la
fusion le point d'orgue c'est
aujourd'hui magna macron est donc en
réalité il ya tout un public qui a le
sentiment que la droite n'a pas trouvé
son expression parce que sans doute
depuis les années 60 il ya eu comme un
yalta intellectuelle qui a fait que la
droite s'est gardé le côté économique
parce qu'elle s'était remise en cause
parce qu'on avait fait on l'avait fait
douter d'elle parce qu'elle doutait
d'elle elle même le complexe du
collaborateur du colonisateur avec une
relecture à gauche de l'histoire assez
partial il faut bien le dire
et donc on a laissé toute la partie
intellectuelle et l'enseignement les
universités à lagos et aujourd'hui eh
bien il ya le sentiment d'avoir du côté
de cette droite conservatrice
si tant est que ce soit pas un pléonasme
de d'avoir été réellement dépossédé de
son corpus et et puis d'avoir été
enfermé parce qu'en fait les
conservateurs n'ont jamais été réels
des ultra libéraux ils sont libéraux
dans le sens où ils ont envie que les
artisans puissent entreprendre mais en
réalité si on dit que les conservateurs
s'inscrivent dans la ligne d'une a été
largement inspirée par la doctrine
chrétienne
eh bien il faut se souvenir par exemple
que c'est dans les penseurs chrétiens
qui ont imaginé en premier la caisse
d'allocations familiales notamment
donc je crois que la droite a une envie
de reconquête et va profiter de cette
espèce de mur qui se dresse face à la
gauche actuellement un petit peu un peu
empêtré dans ses contradictions comme a
pu le montrer la sphère de l'unef paris
micheline sur youtube nous dit la droite
n'est plus très crédibles pour gagner ce
sera difficile faire des promesses c'est
bien mais les tenir c'est autre chose
et puis mother qui est assez sévère pour
gagner la bataille
il faudrait déjà avoir une idée est ce
que toi et morale à la force de la
droite sur la gauche ces deux au moins
ne pas avoir en son sein un élément de
fracturation aussi majeure que la
conduite à tenir vis-à-vis de l'islam
on le voit à gauche on prend le sujet de
l'unef par exemple où le patron du parti
socialiste vient de dire qu' ils
désapprouvaient ces dérives
communautaristes de l'unef alors que la
france soumise dès les soutiens
complètement ou même une partie du ps
comme benoît hamon
à droite il ya peut-être moins de deux
grenades comme ça qui explosent et c'est
peut-être un atout
il ya des sujets qui font qu'ils ne font
pas consensus à droite clairement mais
la vérité c'est en effet que l'actualité
le terrorisme etc a avivé une fracture
sur le rapport à la république qui était
déjà importante entre deux partis de la
gauche chez les familles meuse de gauche
pierre est conciliable de vals et ça
c'est effectivement difficile à dépasser
on ne met il ya beaucoup de choses qui
que la gauche partage c'est à dire que
sur l'écologie elle est d'accord sur la
redistribution elle est d'accord mais
sauf que tous ces sujets là aujourd'hui
sont plutôt secondaire par rapport en
fin dans l'opinion par rapport à la
question républicaine et régalienne au
sens large
donc ça des ventes désavantage la gauche
et on le voit avec le nombre de
candidats probables à la présidentielle
où il y aura donc jean luc mélenchon est
probablement un candidat vert plus un
candidat ps à moins qu'il n'arrive à se
regrouper mais mais on voit bien la
difficulté
merci beaucoup à tout les deux merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis point de vue
reviendra bien sûr demain même endroit
et à la même heure
bonne soirée
[Musique]